let's bring in someone who knows a thing
or two about border enforcement Texas
lieutenant governor Dan Patrick who is a
Republican thank you so much for being
here we really appreciate it so talk to
us about the impact of the National
Guard on the southern border how will
this help Border Patrol and how will it
stop illegal crossings into your state
well first of all Texas has taken the
lead
joining the president in securing the
border in Texas and our budget as
Lieutenant Governor we we have put 800
million dollars into each of our budgets
to do the job that Obama didn't do and
thank God for Donald Trump he campaigned
on this he knew what he was talking
about America reacted America is
supporting him today I heard earlier
you're one guess and something about his
approval rating I think they're up over
50% and with Republicans eighty-five to
ninety percent people get that this
president stands for Americans and not
criminals coming to this country
illegally
so in terms of the National Guard we
welcome it and I hope he leaves them
here until hell freezes over or until
the wall is built because it makes a
difference when Rick Perry called out
the National Guard four years ago as he
was leaving office it made a difference
when you have men and women in uniform
standing on the border it sends a
message to people that we are serious
about protecting our country we're all
in in Texas with President Trump on this
issue certain governor can you expand on
that and how crime from illegal
immigration has affected the state of
Texas both in terms of a human cost and
an economic cost on your state well
let's just look at the facts
I hear Democrats and and liberals on Fox
all the time and other networks decrying
that there are no crimes committed by
illegal immigrants number one in Texas
only in the last seven years we've put
in our jails over two hundred and forty
five thousand criminal aliens these are
the facts we've charged them with over
650,000 crimes either current or on
their rap sheet
we have convictions for 566 murders 274
kidnappings and when President Trump
talks about rape in Texas in the last
seven years 3244 sexual assaults join
that with 40,000 other assaults 40,000
drug crimes thousands of gun crimes and
thousands and thousands of gang members
like ms-13 in this country
committing crimes when I hear the mayor
of Berkeley say sanctuary cities make us
safer
it is nonsense absolute nonsense and in
Texas we passed Senate bill 4 last
February early in our session and it's
been upheld by the courts we now give
the power to police if they want to ask
where you're coming from and asked to
see your documents you can do it in
Texas secondly if Jerry Brown tried to
pull a stunt like he's doing in
California which i think is total
anarchy he's not upholding his oath look
the oath that Jerry Brown took is the
same thing that I took or Governor
Abbott wrote except the state changes
the name but we swear an oath to our
Constitution and to uphold the laws of
the country and our state and Jerry
Brown is not doing it but in Texas if
any of our Democrats defy working with
ice we number one can find their cities
we can arrest those elected officials we
can even run them out of office we're
not putting up with this nonsense in
Texas and America's with the president
America is with Texas that's why
everyone wants to move to Texas yeah
don't mess with Texas that's for sure
just one final thought what kind of
impact is the National Guard going to
have in terms of really bolstering the
efforts of Border Patrol to get back on
the frontlines and do what they need to
do to stem the increased flow of illegal
immigration that we've seen over the
past couple of months well there's a lot
in symbolism first of all and and what
you say the president president Trump
helped the border crossings go down by
just taking a tough stand waiting for
Congress to step up with the the funds
for the wall and mortar board and more
border agents now he's going from
rhetoric to action because Congress
won't act and it's time for Congress to
give him the money for the wall we need
the wall not in every mile there's some
natural barriers and some you can do
electronic but in many areas
particularly around our big cities where
most people cross the border and get
into these big cities and disappear into
the population we need walls around
these major crossings we have 19 alone
in Texas with Mexico so having the
National Guard send a strong message
look if you're from Central America and
that's where a lot of the gang members
are coming with the past 13 and other
gangs and you get to the border and you
see men in military uniforms and women
standing on the border it sends a very
strong message
and and deterrent will cut down it will
be a deterrent it will send them back to
where they went and secondly it will
keep us safer you also mentioned the
economic impact we now act as well as as
well as crime absolutely thank you so
much lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
really hid the president is on target
all right thank you